[Applause]
good evening everyone as principal of
Massey College which is a co-sponsor of
tonights 4th C pharmacy lecture it's my
honor to offer one of the welcomes you
will receive tonight
in doing so I note with respect the
ancestral lands that the Bader theater
and Massey College occupy these are
lands that were originally the lands of
the Huron Linda
Seneca Jib way and Hutton Shawnee the
most recent first nation to own this
land were the Mississauga's of the new
Credit River whose chief chief stay
Selah forum is an elected honorary
senior fellow at Massey along with His
Royal Highness Prince Philip and Sir
Christopher Patton Chancellor of Oxford
University and germane to tonight's
subject matter I would point out that
they out of Shinobi have their own
tradition with respect to sky gazing
they had a group in their first nation
known as the stargazers referred to in
the Anishinaabe language as the web you
know II mean or the Morningstar man and
these are the people who are privileged
to have a full knowledge of the sky
world as available in those days and
these the people who work very hard to
associate day-to-day life with their
understanding of the sky as they could
observe it in their time and place
welcome to the CFR Massey talk on
science and society for the past four
years Massey College and C far have been
working together to bring these science
talks to the public these talks are
intended to explore the connection
between research broader society and
help catalyze new ways of thinking
each year we invited a very
distinguished scholar speaker to discuss
an interesting and important area of
their research tonight we will hear from
CFR senior fellow victoria Caspi who
will be more properly introduced in a
moment and she will speak about
mysterious mysterious cosmic phenomena
called fast rate
bursts and about how researchers are
working to understand them in the
process we will learn a great deal about
how modern astronomy is done about the
nature of our universe and about a new
Canadian telescope that could provide
novel insights into a number of
important questions the sky ever since
the days of the First Nations has been
the object of awe and study and
understanding and a wondrous mix of
observational science new technology and
the genuine appreciation of the larger
universe of which we are a part of
course the Canadian stood for dance
research is itself not only an
interdisciplinary platform for
leading-edge research on so many vital
areas of society but a true generator of
intellectual capital and when you think
about that there are a few Canadians
who have done more to generate new
science in a way that on the HIV issue
literally saved thousands of lives
opened up new doors and Seana great and
broad light in the darkest and most
threatening of environments I'm
delighted to introduce my co-host this
evening the president CEO of CFR dr.
alan bernstein president of CFR but most
importantly a senior fellow of massey
college now
[Applause]
thank you very much you I am delighted
to be here both of you just heard from
principal Siegel as the president of CFR
and as a senior fellow from Massey and
I'm really honored to be having both
those roles and I'm really much very
much looking forward to introducing our
fourth Massey c4 lecture dr. Vickie
Casspi for those of you who are familiar
with CFR who are not familiar with C far
we are Canada's Global Research
Institute we were founded 38 years ago
roughly on two disarmingly really simple
ideas the first is that research is
essential to improve the human condition
now I would add probably more so now
than than ever and second the best way
to do research and to address the really
complex difficult questions that the
planet faces today is to bring the very
best minds together today see far has
close to 400 fellows advisers and
scholars who come from 120 institutions
at 22 countries addressing questions
ranging from understanding the genetic
networks that underlie our health and
disease to the launch of the Revolution
and artificial intelligence to gravity
and the extreme universe which you'll
hear a lot more from our speaker this
evening I believe the CFR gives our
fellows something that is so precious
today which is time time to think
together to come across boundaries of
both discipline and country to really
address interesting and important
questions since 1982 there have been 19
Nobel laureates who have been associated
with C far including we've added one
this week most recently Paul Romer who
is a CFR fellow in our program at
economic growth in the 1990s who won on
Monday the shared the Nobel Prize in
Economics with a colleague and and
actually it's relevant to today's talk
because
what Paul won his Nobel Prize for was
the I think disarmingly simple idea that
ideas and innovation are what drive
economic growth in our economy and he
proved that mathematically and and and
statistically and brought really robust
evidence to the fore something that
certainly as a scientist I almost you
know the air I breathe so now I'd like
to introduce another first-rate mind not
yet a Nobel Prize winner but you know
times on our site this evening speaker
Vicki Caspi Vicki is a Seafarer senior
fellow and she directs our program and
gravity in the extreme universe she's a
professor of physics at McGill
University holds the Lawrence watch a
chair in astrophysics and cosmology and
directs the McGill Institute of space
science Vicki's research focuses amongst
other things on neutron stars which are
massive dense celestial objects that
emit bursts of radiation as they rotate
and that are formed when a massive star
explodes she uses the largest and most
powerful radio and x-ray telescopes in
the world to study their physical
behavior and she also uses a new
telescope I made in Canada telescope
called chyme which I'm sure she will
tell us a lot more about in her talk her
work is shedding light on the matter
nature of matter under really
extraordinary circumstances under these
intense pressures and densities as well
as in less extreme settings right here
on earth
Vicki is the winner of many awards and
honors deserve deservedly including the
gray-haired Hertzberg Canada Gold Medal
the Killam Prize the Peter Martin award
of the Canadian Astronomical Society and
she's a Companion of the Order of Canada
please join me in welcoming Vicki Caspi
[Applause]
thank you very much for that lovely
introduction it's a great honor to be
here I'm very excited to tell you about
some of the research that I'm doing
right now it's in the field of astronomy
and as I described to you the phenomenon
that we're trying to understand it's a
it's a big puzzle it's a major mystery
right now I'm hoping also to share with
you a little bit about the process of
doing research what it's like to be
trying to answer these kind of questions
the twists and turns and as you'll see
lots of surprises along the way a lot of
unexpected things now when we when I try
and explain to people you know what is
what do we mean by fast radio bursts
here's the sort of already kind of
cartoon of the sort of thing I want you
to have in your mind something all over
the sky that's flashing in unexpected
places very briefly and then disappears
and I'll explain a little bit more of
what what this phenomenon really looks
like but that's just that's just to get
you sort of an intuition for the
challenge that we face because we want
to understand a phenomenon where we
don't know when the next one is going to
be or where the next one's going to be
and so it has gotten quite a bit of
attention this this problem here it was
on the on the cover of nature magazine
but another thread that you'll see in
the talk is that it's gotten quite a bit
of press in some some ways that's
wonderful in some ways as you'll
understand it's it's a little strange
here's some examples New York Times LA
Times it's we've been all over the press
people find this phenomenon really
really fascinating now we play fast
radio bursts and when I say radio people
or at least people of a certain
generation picture this device something
that detects
invisible waves with an antenna and
which has a dial on it where you can
change the frequency that that antennas
sensitive to or at least that that is
amplified enough that you can hear it
through the speaker with your ears so
there's a dial here and there's you know
FM which is telling you in megahertz
which has to do with the number of of
oscillations per second of the radio
wave that you're interested in the
frequency of radio waves is going to
play a very big role in this talk and so
I wanted to introduce it using a device
that draw familiar with that of course
when we say radio these waves that are
invisible that you can't see are a form
of light the electromagnetic spectrum is
the full wavelength or frequency
depending on how you want to look at it
of electromagnetic waves of which the
light that you're using to see me right
now is a small part that's the visible
portion of the spectrum but radio is
just another part of the electromagnetic
spectrum it is a much lower much lower
frequency longer wavelength kind of
light but it's light all the same and
nature produces all sorts of different
light when you look up at the sky you're
seeing the visible portion because
that's what your eyes can see but if you
had antennas for eyes the sky would look
vastly different and you might notice
things flashing off and on all the time
and that's called the phenomenon of fast
radio bursts so what does this
phenomenon consist of brief bursts of
radio waves as I said and now I'm going
to quantify brief they last only a few
thousandths of a second
that's a few milliseconds there's a
range there's all sorts of things you
can measure here and we've measured but
and some of them are even less than a
thousandth of a second sometimes tens of
millions of a second something very
brief the first one of these events was
detected in reported in 2007 by a group
using the Parkes radio telescope
nope this is what the Parkes radio
telescope looked like it's you can just
this for scale here I'll use this this
is a 64 meter aperture there's a
three-story building down here I
actually did my PhD in there it's a lot
of fun to work there with the giant
telescope on top of you and as you can
see the radio waves come in and our
focus to focus cabin where there's
antennas that are then the signal is
amplified digitized and read down into
computers in the building downstairs so
since 2007 we've detected about so this
slide is actually a few hours out of
date so we just tagged out its added
yesterday was about thirty of these fast
radio bursts had been detected and today
was just a nature paper announcing the
detection of twenty more so to this
about fifty of them have been detected
since 2007 but we know that the
phenomenon is actually much more common
we can estimate that the all-sky rate
that is all of if you could look at the
entire sky all the time this these
things that are happening about a
thousand times per sky per day so if you
could look everywhere into and add it
all up in 24 hours you'd see about a
thousand of them so it's something
that's ubiquitous in the universe this
isn't uncommon and we had no idea this
existed before 2007 you could ask why
did you find it then has totally totally
coupled with the power of computers
computing power ability to record data
digitized data very fast and then
analyze it also and we have the bottom
line is we don't know where they're
coming from
so something ubiquitous in the universe
of totally unknown origin we don't know
what they are one thing we know is
they're not microwave ovens and that you
may say what's she talking about you'll
understand shortly what I mean by that
now what do they look like so this was
sort of a press photo that was created
this is not what they look like you
can't see radio waves but this is sort
of to give you an idea something goes
bursts and hits the telescope but that's
not what they look like this is what
they really look like to us to
astronomers we take the digitized signal
from the radio telescope and we put it
into computers and we're now showing you
a digital version of what we actually
see and so just look at this inset for a
moment time is going on this axis and
basically there's nothing but noise
coming from the radio telescope
initially and then there's the burst the
burst happens it gets really bright and
then it goes away and it does not come
back so this is that's the burst but
that's actually a simplified version of
what we see in fact the radio telescope
the antenna that's on the radio
telescope and the focus there is
sensitive to a wide range of radio
frequencies and if you look at all the
different radio frequencies that it's
sensitive do that's what this bigger
plot is time is still on this axis so
time is moving along here and on this
axis is radio frequency just like the
dial on that radio I showed you except
we can see all these different
frequencies at once
on that radio you can only listen to
roughly speaking one at a time here we
can listen if you want to a whole range
of frequencies not megahertz gigahertz
in this case but what happens is the
signal does not arrive at all the radio
frequencies at the same time and this is
a phenomenon called dispersion and I'm
going to spend a little bit of time on
it because it's absolutely crucial to
this talk but I really want everybody
understand that the signal arrives
earliest at the highest radio
frequencies and it sweeps through the
band as you look at you're sensitive to
all these frequencies but it it comes in
at the highest radio frequencies first
and it's delayed at the lowest rate at
the lower radio frequencies and you
probably are eyes are drawn to the
stripe here that's some TV station or
something that's a radio station that's
at a fixed radio frequency that's just
no that's a North nuisance to us we know
that's terrestrial this signal by virtue
of
the fact that it sweeps in and arrives
at different times at different radio
frequencies that's the crucial piece of
information that's a this dispersion
phenomena and explain a little bit more
detail is what's telling us that these
events are coming from far far outside
the Milky Way galaxy they're coming in
fact what we infer from that's just that
sweep right there is that they're
probably coming from the furthest
reaches of the universe from what we
call cosmological distances distances
that are appreciable fractions of the
ages of the universe away
that's Dunc Lorimer he led the team that
found the first one of these now when I
say that the events are coming from far
far outside our galaxy and from
cosmological distances I want to be sure
we all understand what that means
so let's talk for a moment about the
scale of the universe you're probably
familiar with this with this artist's
rendition of the solar system you know
this is Sun there's the planets this is
really it's a terrible one you know they
don't travel on rings you know they
they're not this is totally not to scale
there's really a big gap between Mars
and Jupiter asteroid belt and and you
know we're not that close you know you
just you gotta hate scientists sometimes
to take a beautiful picture and just
tear it to shreds but anyway you get the
picture this is the solar system you're
familiar with that but we live the solar
system the whole thing is just a tiny
dot in a spiral galaxy called the Milky
Way this is not the Milky Way you can of
course be sure of that back because you
cannot take a photo at the outside of
your home when you're standing inside of
it not possible this is like probably a
lot like the Milky Way if you could zoom
out and look back and this red dot which
is probably something like a million to
a billion times greater than the size of
the solar system just to be clear I had
to make it this big so you could see it
the solar system is the speck on this
scale is that the outer reach of this
Milky Way galaxy and by the way just to
show some pretty pictures we're in the
galaxy we're in the disk of the galaxy
and so the Milky Way
it look like a spiral to us but it looks
you can see it viewed edge-on because
we're inside of it there but just to
make clear the scale of the universe you
know here's the earth here's the scale
of solar system you can't quite see it
but in any if you can see if they turned
the lights down a little bit here but
the red dot is always the previous scale
in this image so here's a scale of the
solar system of the Sun in the middle
don't know if you could see and this is
now if you zoom out by factors of many
many thousands to millions this is the
interstellar local neighborhood local
area region the closest stars of which
the Sun is just one roughly there in the
center and now zooming out by again a
similar factor an enormous factor you're
now at the scale the Milky Way where
that entire interstellar neighborhood is
on the outer regions of the Milky Way
galaxy and then if you zoom out after
this time not huge factor about a factor
of ten to a hundred
there's the entire Milky Way galaxy in
the local galactic group galaxies like
to be in groups and so this is a group
of galaxies the Andromeda galaxy is
another big galaxies in our local group
and if you zoom way out of that also the
whole local group of galaxies is just a
dot in the super in the Virgo
supercluster of galaxies so galaxy
clusters like to cluster and then if you
zoom out of that again this entire super
cluster of groups of galaxies is a tiny
smudge in local supercluster of galaxies
and then if you zoom way out of that you
get to the observable universe on the
largest scales which is homogeneous and
isotropic looks the same in all
directions it's now a remnant of this
primordial soup that forms it billions
of years ago and this is the scale this
is the distance scale in which we
believe fast radio bursts are arriving
the largest scales in the universe
that's where they're coming from and we
could tell all of that
from that dispersive sweep so let me
explain is that that's quite a claim
okay that's that's that's that's yeah I
gotta unpack that that's that's huge so
well how could we be so sure so let me
just talk briefly about dispersion of
light so you're familiar you're actually
all familiar with dispersion of of
optical light the light that you can see
because when you pass white light
through a prism you know that the prism
splits geometrically the different
colors of white is actually made up of
all those colors together and the prism
splits them and that's also the cause of
the rainbow white water droplets in the
air will split dispersed white light
from the Sun but what you might not
realize is that in addition to the
geometric dispersion there's also a time
dispersion and that if you could pulse
the prism you would see that the colors
arrive in slightly different times
different colors travel at different
speeds in a medium like glass or water
now you might have thought wait a minute
you know a equals MC squared where C is
the speed of light that's a constant of
nature and that's actually true in a
vacuum so as long as that lights
traveling in a vacuum then the speed of
light is constant the same for all
colors of light and that's all across
the full electromagnetic spectrum
optical radio gamma-ray everything see
but in a medium that is not in a vacuum
the speeds are different and space is
not a vacuum so here's some cute little
geeky jokes space interstellar space is
not a vacuum it is filled with all sorts
of different there's dust
there's neutral atoms there's finalized
atoms in particular there's free
electrons there are free electrons
throughout the galaxy I'm going to show
you a nice map of them shortly
and it's those free electrons that
disperse radio waves so
the prism in the analogy between the
dispersion of white light and should
colors the rainbow
the free electrons in our galaxy act as
a prism for radio waves now so I'm just
I'm about to show you a contour plot now
we're be sure all on the same page what
a contour plot is you see contour plots
if you look at maps where the lines are
lines of constant altitude so you can
see you know a mountain here and each
line is sort of has a label on it for
the the altitude and if you walk on that
line the altitude is constant so this we
can do the same thing in the galaxy with
free electrons so we know we've mapped
out using galactic sources and
particularly the neutron stars that I
love to study
here's another spiral galaxy not the
Milky Way you know that this is MIT this
is actually a representation of the
Milky Way galaxy where the darkness the
darker color indicates greater density
of free electrons so we have mapped this
out and this is a contour plot showing
you the same thing where here we are in
the outskirts that's that dot there and
the center of the galaxy is where this
little cross is and these lines are
roughly speaking where our spiral arms
are and these are contours of constant
total number in some arcane units don't
worry about it what it is the total
number of electrons in that direction so
if you if you see some galactic source
from a certain direction you can measure
you can measure the sweep of its radio
waves and then look at the map and it
tells you roughly how far away it is so
we use these kind of maps to measure
from sweeps of galactic radio sources
that bursts distances so we know
something happened a certain distance
there's a certain sweep in how radio
waves arrive that tells us the distance
roughly speaking to the source and in
particular from our knowledge of the
distribution of electrons in the galaxy
from galactic sources we know what the
map
in any direction so we know roughly
speaking from the map and it's a
three-dimensional map you go in any
direction we know how many free
electrons total there are in our galaxy
it's quite well known and so this is how
we determine distances so just here's
your little cartoon the fast radio
bursts source goes off it emits all
radio frequencies at the same time but
as they travel through free electrons in
interstellar and intergalactic space
they get delayed because of dispersion
and spread out and so that's this if
this is again radio frequency in time it
just like a prism spreads out the light
in time different color radio waves they
travel at different speeds in this in
the plasma made of free electrons they
act as a prism and it washes out any
short burst radio a short burst of radio
waves that spreads it out over time so
that if you just added up all the radio
frequencies you would see a totally
smeared out pulse we have to correct for
this effect and the degree by which we
correct is telling us the distance okay
so I hope you were all able to but it's
a little bit complicated if I lost some
of you just understand this from the
amount of sweep here we measure this
sweep the total maximum in the direction
this event came from in those arcane
units of not contour plot was about 25
we know the galaxy can only account for
a much smaller sweep the sweep we saw
was over 10 times it's almost 20 times
the Backson of sweep our galaxy can
possibly produce this is what's telling
us it can't come from our galaxy the
models of the free electrons that we've
built from years and years of
observations with galactic sources tell
us this thing has to be way out
in our galaxy and if and by way outside
a galaxy I mean it has to be at a
cosmological distance because the sweep
is so large an intergalactic space is
even more closer to a vacuum than our
interstellar space inside the galaxy
this thing has to be coming from a
cosmological distance and if it's coming
from a cosmological distance if it's
that far away then intrinsically it must
have been very very bright so you know
this phenomenon it's kind of frightening
this is something you BIC witness a
thousand times per sky per day we don't
know what's causing it but it's the
cosmological distances disabled here on
earth something extremely bright now at
the same time this was discovered at
Parkes they started seeing quite a few
of them but some of them had a slightly
different behavior especially that sweep
that telltale sweep they had kind of
strange frequency sweeps this is one
example of type of fast radio bursts
they called them parrot ons I'm not sure
why they call them that but just they
just to distinguish them from the bulk
of them which were looked much more like
the standard sweep that I've shown you
in the warmer bursts this way it sort of
clumpy and it's sort of broader in
certain frequencies than others and
there were some other anomalous things
about that I don't have time to get into
so they tried why are these a little
different from the others they didn't
really understand until they made a plot
of when they arrived by time of day and
so this is a plot showing the green ones
like the light gray ones are all the
parrot ons and this is time of day in
Australian local time and the dark gray
ones are the normal sweeps and they
noticed that the parrot ons the weird
sweep ones they tended to occur most
often at lunchtime and so this was a
clue that you know how could the
universe know when lunchtime is at local
time at the Parkes telescope that could
not be and what they realized very
quickly once they saw this
plot was it had to be something local
and it turned out so the Parkes
telescope if you have to go there
there's a long road here and at the end
of the road there's the visitors
building where the astronomers can sleep
and get something to eat and it turned
out that a parrot on is created when the
microwave oven is operating and someone
opens it prematurely so it wasn't just
it wasn't as microwave oven had to be on
No somebody had to be impatient and the
telescope had to be oriented roughly in
that direction and if they opened it
when the telescope was roughly orient in
that direction you got a parrot on it
and the grad student who sorted all this
out and you know had a stopped had a
walk o'clock and was a note-taking
open-close open-close and they looked
and they thought exactly parrot ons they
could then predict it and they knew that
those the weird sweep ones those were
not Astrophysical and and I actually I
love telling a story because I'm so
proud to be a scientist this is one of
the most prestigious journals and
astrophysics the Monthly Notices of the
Royal Astronomical Society identifying
the sorts of parrot on that the Parkes
radio telescope and look what they wrote
in their paper subsequent tests revealed
that a parrot on can be generated when a
microwave oven doors opened prematurely
and the telescope of an appropriate
relative angle and knew this is science
this is this is uh it's not just amazing
that they did that they figured it out
but they report it in a prestigious
Journal and I think importantly what it
demonstrated is that the dark gray ones
in that plot the ones that had the more
natural-looking sweep or at least the
sweep that's very consistent with
interstellar dispersion by a plasma
those did not come in any special time
those have to be Astrophysical and so
they comment on that also this and other
distinct observational differences so
that fast radio bursts are excellent
candidates for genuine acts extra
galactic events and we now have seen
that Part B phenomena at many different
telescopes not just those of microwave
ovens so we know they're real and so
what are what are these things you're
you're all wondering I'm wondering we
don't know currently there are more
theories I think even with today's
announcement there are more theories
than there are actual events that have
been detected which is a very strange
place to be but the number of theories I
just listed a few you know exploding
stars something exploding colliding
stars colliding neutron star black hole
this paper on comets and asteroids
impacting neutron stars black holes
evaporating primordial cosmic string
oscillations all sorts of ideas out
there but the bottom line is we don't
know the answer but let me tell you
about a major clue that we got from a
fast radio bursts that was detected at
this Observatory which is the Arecibo
Observatory in Puerto Rico this is now a
much larger telescope than Parkes this
is 300 metres across that's like five
football fields this this structure here
is a large visitor center a beautiful
Museum where many schools in Puerto Rico
bring their kids to learn about
astronomy these are it's a parking lot
down there just to set the scale this is
this is a by the way a catwalk you can
walk on this and there we are me and a
couple friends are at the top of the
catwalk and if you zoom in my knuckles
are white because it's really scary up
there I don't know why we bother wearing
hardhats like they make us wear though
that I don't know and of course this was
featured in a famous film James Bond
Goldeneye and I've never seen this it's
great just to see the Arecibo
Observatory it's it's a really they
incorrectly put it in Cuba in the movie
it's not it's in Puerto Rico but this
one here's the fast radio bursts that we
detected at Arecibo and and you can see
the tail tail to sweep there the
dispersive sweep we haven't we could by
the way we could correct for this and
make it vertical by exactly removing the
dispersion but here we have it and you
see the sweep it actually tends to fade
away at the lower radio frequencies
which is curious this is the burst when
you sum up over all the radio
frequencies
and this was for a long time the only
burst detected by Arecibo and is
actually the first one detected at a
telescope that was not the Parkes
telescope so the Parkes people were
really relieved when we found it because
they were terrified there was something
else going on at their telescope that
they hadn't identified but then we saw
one so they said whew
then we decided that we should be even
those parks have been looking at all the
fast radio bursts they detected and
never seen anything else from those
positions like it was a one-off event we
we sat on this one and and we watched
this position for many many months and
also we didn't see anything
until one day we went back to that spot
and we saw ten more bursts from the same
source and these are this was a big
shock we were not at all expecting this
now I weave in this plot we've taken out
the dispersion just corrected for it
delayed the lower frequencies so that
they line up vertically and you can see
all of the different bursts from the
source some are incredibly bright some
are incredibly weak some are very bright
across all radio frequencies some are
only in the bottom part of the frequency
band this was an amazing shock to us and
it was actually found by a graduate then
graduate student Paul Schultz at McGill
University who just we were all shocked
they it repeats oh it repeats and they
got tons of press everybody was really
excited I'm not sure why there well I'll
tell I have a theory why we get so much
press about these things I'll share it
with you shortly but once you have one
that repeats well that's a big that's
big you know you would really like to
know are these things coming from a
galaxy and with the Parkes events you
can't know that and the problem is that
if you look at the sky that's how well
Parkes can find the position of any
event that they detect okay this every
telescope is some angular resolution
that is some limitation on how well they
can pinpoint the source of the event in
a park that region
very large so that there's thousands of
galaxies there that it could have come
from you can't know and even Arecibo
actually can pinpoint things a little
bit better but still there's hundreds of
galaxies in the error region of the
Arecibo telescope doesn't help you but
you really wanted a different kind of
radio telescope called an interferometer
that can pinpoint things really well the
Very Large Array and we're about to go
there in New Mexico but the problem is
that its field of view is so small so if
you only detect an event once or in
other words Parkes is really good at
flying them because it sees a large area
of the sky at once but it can't pinpoint
anything that can pinpoints can't detect
them because they're looking at too
small fraction of the sky and the things
are bursting elsewhere but once you have
one that repeats you can go with an
interferometer like The Very Large Array
in New Mexico this is an array of 25 on
this case or I forget oh we could count
that i-it's this number of 85-foot
telescopes and you can just stare and
wait and that's exactly what we did we
we said we can there's something that
repeats if you just wait and you look
over there because it pinpoints so well
you're gonna we're gonna know where it's
coming from
and then we can look and see if there's
a galaxy and we looked and looked for
months and nothing happened the source
did not cooperate we had seen it
repeated Arecibo so we knew it did and
eventually they were getting pretty sick
of us at that telescope but eventually
it started at bursts and there was a big
boom and this was incredibly exciting
and right away the analysis the error
the the Arecibo error regions where we
didn't know where it was these were two
different positions that we we knew it
had to be in this overlap region and
there it was on a map made with the with
the Very Large Array and in this is the
Very Large Array data is shown in the
same way that we showed the Arecibo
dated before exactly the same sweep the
same amount of dispersion and within the
air region had to be the source and once
we have that position then so this is
how it were you had that go let's go so
we right to the Gemini telescope this
large 8 metre telescope on the
summit of a mountain in Hawaii we say
okay we know the position can we have
some time and they gave us some time and
here came the next shock so we got we
actually got nine bursts with the VLA so
we got a precise sky position and we
went to the Gemini telescope and looked
and this is what we saw optically like
this tiny little smudge we were
expecting a nice big big galaxy and it
was this tiny little smudge of a galaxy
turns out there's these it was
incredibly faint we really needed an
eight large eight meter telescope to
detect that the fast radio bursts was
coming from a dwarf galaxy so it turns
out there's many different types of
galaxies and they're not all giant
beautiful spiral galaxies like the Milky
Way there's all these smaller galaxies
and this huge radio burst said was
coming there's a total shock we have no
idea from a dwarf galaxy but the good
thing was that even though it's a tiny
galaxy we could still measure an
independent distance because it's
possible to do that with galaxies is it
there's a nice way those of you know
using spectroscopy you can measure the
redshift we measured it and we knew we
had measured it was really at a
cosmological distance so all that
business of the dispersion and
estimating from the free electrons you
know you could have questioned maybe you
don't know what you're doing but in fact
it exactly agreed with what we predicted
from the dispersion so we knew it's
definitely the cosmological distance
there was a McGill postdocs tree Harsha
Tendulkar who who did this wonderful
optical work and then we got so much
press this way another another press
machine went out and even fought here
Fox News that was really exciting Fox
News surprise monster bursted radio
waves arose and tiny galaxies and and
you know all this press let me let me I
said I would say why I think we get so
much press he for example okay here's
the New York Times the famous science
writer Dennis Overby did a large article
about it's a radio burst traced a
faraway galaxy but caller is probably
ordinary physics that wasn't wasn't so
thrilled with that I really like to to
visit it his home late at night and set
off a fast radio bursts but see how
ordinary he finds it
but meanwhile new york post aha
scientists a radio signals could be
coming from aliens like where did they
get that and how we never said that but
i do think a lot of the press that we
get has to do with us using terms like
radio signals which might suggest to
some people that this is not a natural
phenomenon that was never our intention
to suggest anything like that we are
very confident this is a natural
phenomena has nothing to do with any
intelligent you know
life-forms but we hit a lot of press out
of its though in any case i don't think
they're aliens just want to be crystal
clear about that
so everybody is where do we stand so at
least one FRB repeats and so far none
other husbands need to repeat so our
SIBO one is still unique obviously a
neutron star can't collide over and over
and over again okay so immediately that
source ruled out a whole class of models
anything cataclysmic anything where the
source of the event destroys itself in
the process well that's out at least for
that one source and we have confirmed
for that source that there indeed
cosmological as we had inferred
indirectly from the dispersion but the
open questions do they all repeat do
some just repeat more often than others
we don't know what is the bursting
source what keeps repeating we don't
know and why is it in a tiny little
galaxy you know we might you might have
thought something that bright would be
in a larger galaxy so you know basically
there's all these puzzles lots of
unanswered questions still we need to
find more of these and that's where this
new telescope that chime telescope that
we've built in the near Penticton
British Columbia comes into the picture
so this is when I say telescope that's
probably not what you would picture this
is an unusual design for a telescope and
I'm going to explain shortly why it's so
fantastic and it is in fact the world's
most powerful fast radio bursts detector
today it can
of four cylinders cylindrical reflectors
so it's very different geometry from the
standard dish circular dish aperture
that I've shown you in parks and Arecibo
which are the standard kinds of radio
telescopes this has four cylinders each
of which is 20 meters by a hundred
meters so the total area here so I told
you I receive on football fields this is
in Canada so it's about five hockey
rinks in total area and basically on the
axis of each of these cylinders are
hanging 256 radio antennas that are
sensitive in the frequency range 400 to
800 megahertz and that means each each
antenna actually has two different
signals so that's a total of a thousand
24 antennas times two two polarizations
for those of you know that's 2048 input
signals that all are going into what we
call basically a massive supercomputer
that is on-site the total input data
rate after did you know digitizing these
signals going into the supercomputer is
13 terabits terabits per second which is
comparable to the entire cellular
network in the world so we have
basically it's telling that in the world
all being reduced in real time as part
of this telescope and this is a
collaboration the lead institutions
McGill University of Toronto UBC and
National Research Council the Dominion
radio Astrophysical Observatory in
Penticton and we also have collaborators
of perimeter the US National Radio
Service astronomical observatory West
Virginia University MIT Yale and
Carnegie Mellon here in University of
Toronto there's a really strong group
playing leadership role in fact some of
some of them are in the audience here
and I don't want to embarrass them but
if you want to waive any trying people
here there's one there are two yay
yeah so just as I'm going to emphasize
this telescope is being built basically
by graduate students and postdocs it is
big science world-leading science and
yet a really student-led trainee LED
effort and it's totally funded by the
Canada foundation for innovation and
here's just for scale there's the fast
radio chime fast radio bursts project
team standing in the access and and this
is now just to give you a feeling for
how large this thing is is the drone
video where you can see first of all you
might ask why would you put this near
Penticton British Columbia the answer is
because it's actually surrounded by
mountains that act as a natural shield
against man-made radio interference
which is ubiquitous now everybody has a
cellphone it's the a lot of terrestrial
interference that's a very big problem
for us and we spend a lot a lot large
fraction of our time just trying to
remove man-made signals in order to
tease out the fast radio bursts and you
can I just want to point out here
there's a little house under these two
dishes here and there's another one
under the other two dishes there's a
whole method amount of electronics going
on in there that are handling this 13
terabits a second that's part of our our
correlator now you might say was okay
why cylinders why would you build such a
crazy geometry now the answer is
basically that you know stack
conventional radio telescope like parks
with circular aperture it can see it you
know it's a different part of the sky
but it's still much smaller than the
full sky and when you have a phenomenon
that's transient where you don't know
the next one is you have to get awfully
lucky to have one in your field of view
and they do get lucky occasionally but
in ten you know ten eleven years they've
seen 30 so even though it's a thousand
for sky per day they don't catch most of
them but with a cylinder it doesn't
focus in one direction it only focuses
in one direction doesn't focus the light
to a point it focuses it to a strip so
you get a much larger
view of the sky so if that's the parks
field of view now's the the chyme fields
of view is much much larger and so you
just have a much greater chance of
having one of these transient events in
your field of view for you to detect now
chunk has no moving parts so it stares
only at what's overhead but fortunately
the sky rotates because the Earth
rotates car rotates every day so we
covered the full northern sky every
single day and in fact the telescope was
designed not for fast radio bursts but
for to do cosmological mapping of
neutral hydrogen gas in the distant
universe for cosmology purposes it just
so happens it's fantastic for transient
science too and you can see a bit why
why won't you advance there so this is
sort of a little technical draw diagrams
but you can see the four cylinders and
all the signals coming in to those two
little Hut's that is what we call the F
engine where we have a whole series of
field programmable gate arrays built at
McGill University for processing those
13 terabits that's it's sent to the X
engine which is based on GPUs if you're
if you're into is led up here at a
University of Toronto and then the
signal from this portion of this it's
kind of like supercomputer 256 computers
is then splits and it can make this map
that's used for cosmology can also study
pulsars but it's also producing the data
set that goes into detecting fast radio
bursts and if you these little shipping
containers on the side here are where
the the X engine and the fast radio
bursts electronics it's a complicated
software pipeline in there and just to
show you the inside of one of those
shipping containers contain just massive
racks cooling units and here are some of
the students and postdocs who put all of
this together really amazing work that
these people did
chime had its first light ceremony in
September 2017 with Canadian federal
minister of science Kirsty Duncan she
went up right on to the focus and
snapped the last few antennas into place
to make China operate and here's some
pictures of the trainees the amazing
students and postdocs who do so much of
the hard work on in fact isn't that you
Chery there she is there and cabling and
now here's how we see the sky so this is
a chime view of the sky now basically
that correlator
allows us to see positions a whole
basically thousand independent positions
on the sky within that massive strip
it's like having a thousand Parkes
telescopes at the same time so is a huge
amount of data that we're processing but
what you can see here this is basically
a view of all the different north-south
directions within that strip as a
function of time these these large
strips that you see going totally
north-south at one time that's actually
a airplanes passing overhead we could
see that with the telescope these
horizontal strips that are fixed in
North that are basically fixed in North
sky position but that go through as a
function of time that's a Galactic radio
pulsar that is that's on and is just
following the rotation of the earth so
it's a very bizarre way of looking at
the sky but this is how we see the sky
and I'm very proud to report that just
this past July try and started saying
fast radio bursts so this is the first
event that we detected we put out an
astronomical telegram we actually
detected it in two neighbouring
positions on the sky because it hit
right between the two of them and we've
removed the dispersion here but it was
heavily dispersed and you can see lovely
lovely bursts the first time it had been
seen at these radio frequencies by the
way it's the lowest radio frequency
these things have been seen at yet we're
very very excited in back in January
nature magazine
wrote an article about what to expect in
2018 the biggest science ish science
areas coming out and the very first
thing they mentioned no pressure here is
a chime and fast rating a birth so it's
a very very exciting time and we're all
working very hard to get this science
out fast but I can't yet tell you what
they are but we are working on it and
I'll just ask you to stay tuned and
thank all of the people working on this
wonderful experiment and especially
Canada foundation for innovation and CFR
that has played a fantastic role in
getting the researchers that these
various universities to to work together
as it is an amazing Canadian team to to
bring this clients both the Canada into
the world and I thank you very much for
your attention stay tuned there'll be
big news from China in the coming months
thank you
[Applause]
make yourself comfortable
okay it is now my great privilege to
introduce Deborah Locke Horst who is a
junior fellow at Massey College she is a
third-year PhD candidate working with
Professor Bob Abraham and the dragonfly
telephoto array telescope her work
includes designing and implementing an
instrumental upgrade for the dragonfly
and she will use this upgrade to study
the properties of galaxies and how they
interact with the cosmic web during her
time at the University of Toronto she's
also worked with professor Keith
vanderlin and he racks which is a South
African radio telescope designed to
trace large scale structures in the
universe
she holds a combined honours bachelor's
degree in physics and astronomy at the
University of Victoria Deborah will ask
her own question or questions and then
she will moderate any questions which
you're invited to offer to our very
distinguished guests Deborah
hi again Vicky alright thank you so much
for the fascinating talk my pleasure
so I do have a billion questions but
I'll try to keep my part short and then
we'll open up the floor for questions
from the audience so fast radio bursts
are just fascinating
so you've listed a bunch of theories do
you have a favorite theory for what fast
radio bursts could be well I I like to
stay in them partial as possible but
there's a lot of hints and even in what
I told you today there's a lot more
phenomenology that I didn't have time to
go into but so it's something that brief
something that's so short it has to be
some sort of compact object it can't be
a big large object that can produce such
massive amounts of light in such a short
period of time it has to be compact and
so that pushes you to neutron star or
black hole seems those are the you know
smallest densest objects that could
potentially produce the sort of energies
that we need also to get that kind of
energy likely the emission has to be
beamed in a certain way to have it be so
narrow and so beaming compact objects
smells too and astrophysicists like
there's magnetic fields involved so I
don't have so you among the theories of
neutron stars or black holes a lot of
them explain most of the observations
but none of that really explains all of
the observations and so I don't even
though you know those tend to be the
ones that astrophysicists gravitate
toward because there are familiar
examples of those phenomena of neutron
stars black holes and the observed
universe I also wouldn't want to rule
out something that we really haven't
even considered yet because who knows
right yeah I guess one familiar object
could be pulsars so yeah there are and
and I worked on pulsars before changing
Herbies I worked on pulse eyes for you
know almost 25 years and so I'm a big
pulse ox fan and yet I wouldn't go
I wouldn't go to that immediately I I
think it's possible but there's lots of
problems with that there's no pulsar in
our galaxy that has produced the amount
of energy you need to be seen at a
cosmological distance by a terrestrial
radio telescope it's it's orders of
magnitude off so it's hard to see how it
could be a pulsar but I wouldn't rule
that entirely so I can we detect these
fast radio bursts in other wavelengths
of light
have they been just detected in the
visible nope
so people have tried but the problem is
that optical there so optical telescopes
that are don't usually have the sort of
field of view that you need in order to
see these kind of flashes
actually somehow the field of view but
they don't have the fast time resolution
so there are optical telescopes that can
see a large area the sky that looked for
supernovae or something by looking for
changes in stars you know from one day
to another but not on a millisecond
timescale people have gone with optical
telescopes to look at positions of fast
radio bursts a few hours to days after
the burst was seen looking for what we
call an afterglow that if something
exploded there maybe there's some light
trailing off that and there have been
suggestions of afterglow seeing the
optical but apps
nothing nothing proven nothing
convincing so people are looking we have
looked at the repeater in x-rays we did
not see any x-rays from the repeater so
no there are no counterparts yet but I
don't think we've really ruled out there
being is just it's hard to do that
science yeah
that makes sense so are there are other
radio telescopes that are also looking
for fr means like chime clearly as you
said yeah so the thing that's special
about chime is it's huge its its large
field of view so that if you you how men
umber of Fr bees we can detect per day
is large compared to most telescopes not
most all telescopes so but other
telescopes have gotten there a little
sooner so the ASCAP telescope in
Australia just an added nature paper
today came out with 20 fr bees but
that's 20 spread over about I think I'm
not sure exactly how long it took it in
a year or something like that
whereas we're hoping to see a comparable
number you know each week or month so
that the data rate of 13 terabytes per
second yeah I had a big bee there should
have been a little bit stir abit Tara
Baker was right sorry
even that that seems pretty impossible
to store that amount of do you know we
cannot store it so do you just how do
you handle that data rate do you end up
throwing most of that away we don't
throw it away it gets processed and
added together and combined and analyzed
and distilled into forms that are more
compact and so for the fast radio bursts
instrument in in that shipping container
that I showed you with the guys and this
computer racks that actually ends up
getting a hundred and forty gigabytes
per second and so it's distilled from
the 13 terabit per second it gets down
to about 140 gigabytes per second and
then that gets processed in real time to
look for fast radio bursts so that our
goal actually as we detect these is to
detect them in real time from that data
stream and then send out alerts to the
canasa physical community to anybody
public alerts so other people with
telescopes can know to go look over
there trying to take chime event over
the
then they'll go swing and maybe they'll
to be able to TechEd an optical
afterglow they just needed the
opportunity and and our goal a sue that
we're not quite there yet know what but
but soon we'll be able to do that right
okay just one last question yeah
so that the repeater yeah are we are you
guys still watching that way yeah it's
been it is being watched
it's it's really an amazing source it's
been detected all the way to very high
radio frequencies it hasn't yet been
detected at a lower radio frequencies
but at these frequencies yeah yeah we
have we haven't we're looking we're
still looking hoping nothing but it's
really interesting because it's very
unpredictable and the bursts tend to
come in clusters yeah so it'll be sia a
silent for a long time doesn't do
anything and then burst burst burst
you'll see so we sit sometimes seen like
10 verse in an hour after not seeing
anything for weeks right so very hard to
predict the births are clearly not
random I always say that with hesitation
because then people say not random but
it doesn't mean it still could be
natural it's just not it's just they're
they're clustered for some reason yeah
that's so interesting
okay before I take over the rest of our
time I wanted to open the floor to get
some questions from the rest of you ah
there's a couple microphones going
around so I can't can you please repeat
I couldn't hear
well compared to the speed of light how
fast these radio waves travel and if
they come from let's say trillions of
light years away is it possible that the
source doesn't even exist anymore is it
possible that way that the source
doesn't exist anymore what else we talk
about yes so so first of all the the the
time difference due to the dispersion of
light so this the difference in speeds
is its small so it's close to it's still
close to the to the speed of light and
if you saw the amount of dispersion for
example the difference in the the time
for AHA the highest frequency radio wave
and with trying to lowest frequency
radio wave it's it's seconds so seconds
but out of a you know a light travel
time that's that's billions of light
years so it's a tiny difference but
absolutely the the source that created
it is billions of light years away
whether it exists today
we don't know but we're looking into
history because it's taken light a very
long time to reach us so the the event
happened billions of years ago I have we
can't know what it's doing today because
it's the light takes that long to travel
to us yes thanks her look fascinating
talk I have a bit of difficulty
understanding what a bright radio source
what would would mean I so if I could
think of it the way you describe is sort
of Justin Janice can you maybe make a
comparison what would that look like if
it was visible if it was if it was
invisible it was in the visible part of
the spectrum what would we see when when
this flash went off right so let me let
me put it this way so it's it's hard to
relate the brightness we could relate it
in terms of energy
example because if a photon comes in
with a certain amount of energy radio
photons are very very low energy so if I
took the energy in one of these you know
it it's very very hard to detect an
optical you know from the same distance
we put that energy you wouldn't see it
but some of the fast radio bursts that
have been detected are as bright as or
comparably bright to the brightest radio
sources in the sky so we have a crazy
unit of measurement called the Jansky
and so some things about the brightest
one something can write like 200
shamsky's now to relate it to something
that is intuitive you have if you go up
another factor of 10 or so then it would
be a brief flash of static on your
analog antenna on your television set
so there are Blackduck objects that that
in fact a pulse are the the crab pulsar
has we call them giant radio pulses that
if you were looking at your TV when it
happened and now I'm talking about the
old old-style TVs with the analog
antennas you would be able to detect
that with a television antenna on your
TV so that's about a factor of 10
brighter than the brightest fast radio
bursts that we've seen and the range of
brightness is a fast radio bursts that
we've seen is is fairly large so they go
down by probably a factor of almost 100
fainter than that thank you I have three
questions actually first like it's
actually a significant statement that if
the FRP is clustered so is it only
clustered in time or is it also
clustered in space you can give me the
theater yeah oh you are saying the
computer yeah the repeaters bursts are
clustered in time and they're all coming
from exact
the same position on the sky and no
other FRB are residing yeah so we keep
looking at the other FRB positions but
have not seen any repeats from any other
one okay the second question is like how
accurate can chime decide the position
of the FRP now like how confident are
you for finding the host galaxies right
those right so chimes there's a typical
region of the typical uncertainty on the
sky for chime will be very similar in
general to the error range of the Parkes
telescope so if you remember the biggest
circle so it's not good enough to
localize two galaxies but but okay this
there's two big busts there
one is that shine sees the same sky
every single day so the Earth rotates
and we get to see the position of every
fast radio bursts that we detect every
single day and so what my hope is is
that we will identify many repeaters so
it can't be that the Arecibo event is
the only repeater in the universe like
that just can't be right
and so but chime it's very well placed
to find other repeaters and as soon as
we start identifying repeaters then we
can go to an interferometer and say
there's a repeater there and and they
can stare at it and pinpoint it for us
and then we can go and do what you want
the problem is that we can find so many
repeaters we'll need all the time
available on the Very Large Array and
all the other astrophysics of the
astrophysics community will hate us and
so we can't see that because there's
other science to do with interferometers
- and there's only one VLA so we're
going to run into that problem which is
why we have another idea that we really
want to pursue we can make an
interferometer of chimes so if we can
make other mini chimes and put them
around north america we can use them as
an interferometer and that is something
that we're actively thinking about and
hoping to pursue once we get this
project fully fully rolling and rolling
along and the
last question is as the rate of FRB
detection increases dramatically with
time what do you expect to do as the
first thing to study but the fr week
yeah so this is so many things so when
you have a very large sample of them so
this is one of the interesting questions
is are they uniformly distributed on the
sky so if they're cosmological you
should they should be fully uniform on
the sky and from the 13 own so far they
seem to be uniformly distribute on the
sky except that it's a if they seem to
avoid the plane of our galaxy and so
cosmological populations should not know
anything about our galaxy but there's
material in the Galactic plane there's
extra free electrons there that could
cause some suggestions that that might
hinder the ability to detect them and
there's good reasons for that so we can
test that sort of thing and you might
expect to see over densities of fast
radio bursts in certain regions of the
sky because galaxies like to cluster and
so if effort beads come from galaxies
eventually you should start to see the
imprint of what we call large-scale
structure on the distribution of effort
bees in the sky so when you have a large
sample you can do that but you can do
other things you can look at the
distribution of dispersion measures you
can look at the distribution of whips
you can look and see is there a
brightness dispersion measure
correlation so I could go on and on
about what we can do with just even
without localizing chime events there's
tons of science that will give us clues
to they might not give us the final
answer but they're gonna get us further
towards solving the problem before I
always get to ask the dumb question so
here's my dumb question Vicki um it has
to do with the origin the material
origin of FRB or FRBS
so implicit in the question of where do
they come from are you assuming they all
come from the same kind of source yeah
that's that's a great question so I
think I asked you that at Whistler
action oh wait I don't know if I'm gonna
ask you again
because this is now a year later so you
should have answered well we don't have
the answer yet yeah
and already when you have one that
repeats and the others don't seem to
repeat yeah that's Jeff's right there
that there's different phenomenas that
we've now we basically opened the sky
and it looked at it in a different way
because computers are so fast and
because we can tweak we have this
technology that allows us to see the
fast transient universe there's many
different types of objects that can
produce radio bursts and you know in the
70s 80s and 90s there was a different
problem called the gamma-ray giris
problem and some of you might have heard
of that where there were bursts of gamma
rays going off around the sky and that
has been studied and and solved largely
and the dirt did turn out to be three
different classes of gamma-ray burster
so there's no reason to think that there
can't be different classes of fast radio
bursts among the sources there we've
already detected what an amazing talk an
amazing discussion I want to invite all
of us to thank Vicki and Deb for
dysphoria
[Applause]
now you know why I have the best job in
science and on the planet actually I
have 400 Nicky Cass bees that to deal
with so I want a special thank you to
you Vicky for coming this way and a
special thanks to you Deb for for great
questions really great questions I also
would like to have a special thank you
to principal Siegel shortly after he
became principal Rebecca Finley and I
came to see you and asked them he would
be interested in having a some kind of
series like this and I think it's the
his great credit that he immediately
agreed and I think it reflected his his
openness is understanding of the
importance of science and the
understanding of science to society and
and here we are with our fourth great
lecture series and I'm going on about
about Hugh because he announced a little
while back now that he'll be stepping
down as the principal of Massey College
some time after this summer or at some
point after I think our truly remarkable
a five-year term as principal Massey
call us enough I want to take this
opportunity publicly Hugh for your
generosity of spirit the partnership
we've had the recognition of the
importance of science to the world
especially in this troubled time when
science and evidence are being tossed
into a sort of a maelstrom of
partisanship and ideology and so your
your vision has been really terrific and
you've been a great partner to work with
Hugh has had I'm sure we all know this
but has that she had a truly
distinguished career as principal
secretary to prime minister Mulroney and
I'm probably going to leave out some
things he was a senator a distinguished
senator and now he's been principal of
Massey College and he's what Kennedy's a
lot more of which is that public
intellectual I feel really privileged
I've worked with you both and my job as
president of C far and it's a senior
fellow at Massey and I wish you really
the best as you as you go on from Massey
College thank you very much
[Applause]